Where do you think MMA is headed?
When you,
when you,
you look at the sport and you,
do you have a sense,
I mean you,
you've obviously been there from the beginning.
Do you have a sense of the direction?
I have an idea.
You know what I think is going to happen.
It's everything has got to evolve or a dies.
Right?
All right.
And when you talk about the evolution,
there's evolution for fighters,
there's evolution for promoters,
there's evolution for fans as far as what they get to watch and how they get to
watch it.
And all of that has to evolve for the sport to continue to rise and build.
When the UFC sold,
you know,
and this is no disrespect to anyone.
Look at the greatest thing that the UFC had was Lorenzo Fertitta.
I'm just being honest.
Dana was fantastic for the UFC as far as his work effort and the amount of work
he put into it.
And you know,
nonstop just going after deals,
trying to make things happen.
You know,
he was the work horse for it,
but the rental is the brains behind it.
You know there's a wizard,
oh my God.
And the loss of him is great.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's already,
you've already seen things.
Well it's also the,
the issue is the price.
They had to pay $4 billion for something that's probably worth two.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm not a business person but,
but again,
seems like a lot of it.
How did it get,
you know,
how did it get to that point where they,
exactly.
Yeah,
he's a wizard.
He is,
he,
you know,
and that's,
but it is one of those things that you look and you go,
all right,
things have,
they've changed and the,
and the way he went about doing things,
cause look at the one thing that Lorenzo was not afraid of with spending money
right now.
That's how the UFC survived.
You know that here's a guy that gambled and he was 54 million because he has $44
million in the hole.
And when he then put 10 million more into the ultimate fighter.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
that was a,
that was a time buy and he paid for all the production and it launched the
sport.
Absolutely.
Because you know he deserves everything that he got from that and he deserves
that giant pay out.
No doubt about it.
My concern is that the monthly nut is so gigantic that I just wonder if like
some people say there's too many fights,
they said it's too many fights,
too many televised fights and that this is,
you know,
this is a part of the,
that saturated traded,
so it's very difficult to sell the paper views because people are like,
no,
I'm not going to buy this when I get to watch next week on fs one,
there's a big card.
I'm just gonna wait for that.
And that's true.
You look at it for a while there,
they were almost competing against themselves with paper views and it was you
had to pay per views in a month and you went and said,
I'll buy that one.
I'm not going to buy that one.
Yeah,
you can't be in business against yourself.
They got rid of that.
There's also mistaken,
they kind of especially initially did a lot of sort of Hollywood style
promotion.
Like when I thought there was a real problem was when Ronda Rousey was making
her come back against Amanda Nunez and they weren't even mentioning Amanda
Nunez.
Mike,
you guys are out of your fucking mind.
Okay.
This is the,
this is the woman that I was saying before.
Rhonda got one that's down by Holly Holm.
I was saying,
Amanda Nunez is more dangerous.
She's fucking dangerous,
man.
Especially see her in this last weekend against Raquel Pennington and like,
Holy Shit just got good.